they just don't have the education so
our own doctors do not have enough
education in something that we do a
third of our lives
if you are waking up in the middle of
the night and it's been happening to you
over and over again
to resolve the habit you're going to
have to
sleep it's a thing that we all do every
day but for some reason in our society
it's still a little bit of a mystery
how many hours should we be sleeping
what is sleep debt
is there a perfect sleep routine should
i wake up at a certain time
why do i get sleep paralysis insomnia
why do i have these dreams
my next guest stephanie romichevsky
worked with nasa
and harvard medical school to understand
these questions
stephanie currently works as a sleep
physiologist helping people
cure and understand their insomnia and
sleep disorders so without further ado
my name is stephen bartlett and this is
the diver ceo i hope nobody is listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
stephanie the first question i wanted to
ask you and i've got
millions and millions of questions to
ask you because this is a
topic which i as i said before we
started chatting on air
um has really peaked an interest over
the last three years i've never had so
many of my friends in my
sort of close circle ask me questions
about sleep send me articles about sleep
and i don't know what's happened but as
a nation and as a as a species i think
we've got really really curious about
this idea of sleep and also its
importance
the first question i wanted to ask you
was a was how important sleep is but
i think a better way to understand that
and the answer is to actually look at
the consequences you've seen
in your line of work um for people that
have
bad sleep or that have insomnia um so
could you speak to that a little bit
i can that's a big big question yeah um
what i have seen over the last 16 years
of my career
is not people coming in dying because
they aren't sleeping
or with really really significant
illnesses i've seen people
very anxious very stressed very low
because their sleep is poor and they are
extremely worried about it
and i've seen people who are you know at
the top of their game and doing
really well in life but are completely
crippled by these sleep problems but it
is the fear
of bad things worse things happening to
them that is keeping them
as stressed and upset as they are so
it's quite interesting because i think
the
the things that bring people to me to
get their sleep treated
are exactly that that fear is actually
what i'm trying to alleviate rather than
um
fixing their sleep because i think
they're going to get so sick that
something terrible is going to happen to
them
and so it's a really interesting
question to ask how does sleep affect us
the reality is we actually we or why do
we sleep
we don't know actually why we sleep we
know what happens when we don't sleep
but i think we're getting very very
confused between
those of us that struggle with sleep and
those that are actively depriving
themselves of sleep like the ceo who
says
i'll sleep when i'm dead for example
sure um
but you know those of us who are
actively trying to sleep when we can't
and we will do anything and we we make
our sleep opportunities larger
and we still can't get sleep we're not
depriving ourselves of sleep we're doing
anything we can to get sleep
so i i worry about the amounts
out there about sleep at the moment and
the way that it's the information is
being disseminated because i think
that's where we're going a bit wrong and
all the tracking of sleep and all the
tech that comes out i'm not saying it's
it's a bad thing i'm just saying that
it's almost like we haven't quite caught
up with all the information that we have
and we can't cope with it quite the way
we need to
so you speak about the tech that we have
now
apple watches all these little you know
smart devices that are telling us how
many hours a day we're sleeping
and also there's you know books there's
probably a couple books on the shelf
behind me about the perfect night's
sleep or the perfect morning routine or
the perfect time to wake up
where is the [ __ ] oh my god
again another massive question um
there is so much of it it's it's all
it's so nuanced you're going to have to
ask me some specifics because
there is so much there that actually is
i mean
well the first thing the biggest thing i
would say is you know
going to bed at exactly the same time
every night dictating your bedtime is
probably the worst
piece of advice i've ever heard and
sends people off on all sorts of
different tangents which does not help
if anything it makes their insomnias
worse because they go to bed
in the dark not able to sleep getting
more anxious
heart rate going up what should they do
instead stay up until they're sleepy
don't worry about it enjoy yourself
relax
do the things that you probably don't
get time to do because you're busy doing
all the other things during the day
is the problem i have with that approach
which is the approach that i think i've
adopted maybe a little bit too much or
incorrectly
is if i stayed up doing the things that
i want to do what happens is i'll stay
up till 7 am just looking at youtube
videos and learning about rockets and
looking at like stocks to invest in and
stuff that's that's me to a t i at some
point i have to put my laptop down and
be like steve just
you're going to feel awful tomorrow if
you can looking at this investment fund
that you think is interesting
yeah absolutely so to a degree you can i
mean we can manipulate our bodies to do
anything in a lab i could manipulate
your body to sleep when i wanted it to
sleep
um but that's taking away all the
environmental factors all the behavioral
factors of your life
um and what you're doing now you know
what it's not the end of the world you
know you're obviously coping with it and
you're healthy and the problem is you
probably won't be able to sustain that
and
unfortunately we are built in such a way
that kind of goes with the
the light dark cycles on this planet um
and so to a degree you are sort of going
against that and unfortunately we've got
lots of other
we've got lots of research showing that
after a while you just can't do that
forever without implication
um so it's not i mean if you think about
it insomnia is just a different pattern
of sleep you've just trained your brain
to sleep differently
and you're still surviving with it it's
just that most of us don't like that
because it's not the rest of society in
the way that they're sleeping
and our friends are sleeping and it
feels like we're the only ones awake in
the night
i bet if you didn't have all those
things to do and you weren't the way you
were and you were up at night and
everybody else around you was asleep
it would start to feel like a very
lonely um anxious place we're not very
rational at night we're not really
made to think in the middle of the night
so not incredibly rational
so i don't think it's the end of the
world what you're doing but at the same
time
put it this way i treat a lot of
entrepreneurs
when they've retired and they're still
fairly young but not in a good place
because
they have not followed anything that
was fairly going along with what our
physiological processes want to do our
bodies are all about regulation we have
clocks in every cell
in every part of our body and they like
regulation they like
time they like the timing of things to
be ready and
and regular and when we keep changing
those goal posts it might seem like
we're being uber flexible
but actually the reality the reality is
is that later on down the line
you'll probably find that you won't be
able to cope with it as much
and how does that manifest itself for me
so so for you if you just carried on the
way you were then unfortunately yeah we
probably would see that um
maybe you were getting less sleep than
you needed um it probably would be
harder for you
maybe when you settled into a routine
where you were
working around the same hours every day
say you got a certain kind of
role that you had to do which made you
know you had to have a certain schedule
you might find it quite difficult after
a while to stick to that schedule
and you might find that you aren't able
to sleep as much as you want the
duration
and the quality will be impaired and so
you might start
all the research around sleep and how
important it is for you
you might start noticing things like
your cognitive abilities
are less so your memory things like that
um your ability to
produce cytokines so the proteins that
help us with
keeping ourselves healthy and keeping
inflammation at bay and things like that
all those kind of things will be reduced
your healing so when you go and weight
training
or something like that or you go to the
gym and you want your muscles to repair
they're not going to be able to do that
so well and of course that over time
short term
it's not a problem over time long term
that's when we start worrying about
more significant illnesses and um
disorders that are happening as we get
older and so that's why we see lots of
research showing
that as we get older maybe some of these
things
like alzheimer's might be related to how
we treated our sleep when we were
younger however
i hate it i hate mentioning things like
that because i think
it frightens people and the problem is
with frightening people is that they go
into what they think is most
logical things to do so they might go
away after this podcast and think oh my
god
i've just got to go away and get my
eight hours because the rest of the
information is telling them
out there that they've got to get this
eight hours of sleep every night
um and of course they can't just get
that you can't dictate to your body how
it sleeps
there is a process it follows it and so
unfortunately you can never force
yourself to sleep you can force yourself
not to sleep and that is partly how you
fix a
sleep problem but you can never force
yourself to sleep but you can induce
anxiety and stress and depression
through that
and lack of sleep so yeah in um
if you're an expert in this field so you
must as you kind of spoke to there you
must get pretty
i can feel it when you're speaking get
pretty pissed off when you see
unhelpful information um being pushed on
i don't know social media or online or
through books these
sort of simplified narratives what are
some of the most um common
misconceptions that you speak to your
patients about
you've mentioned one there about this
like eight hours of sleep being
the optimal yeah and even when i put out
on my instagram earlier what are the key
questions you want to ask
um i'm speaking to a sleep therapist
expert today um
i'd say the vast majority or at least
the medium question was
uh do i need to get exactly seven or
eight hours sleep
every single night yeah um yeah so that
is definitely the biggest one we get um
you do not
that perfection is the enemy of the good
have you ever heard that term because at
the end of the day it's true
yes your body loves consistency and
regulation but that does not mean you
have to get
eight hours of sleep every night think
about it differently think about it over
a month for example
we love this idea of the way the way we
look at time is slightly different to
the way your body looks at time
and over a month you might actually be
all right so maybe one night you get
six and a half hours the next night you
get seven and a half and then the next
night you might get slightly different
as long as it's fairly consistent and
maybe eighty percent of the time you're
doing fairly well and you're you're
giving yourself the right opportunity to
sleep
that's okay your body's gonna do it you
know it will do what it needs to do
and and with that a caveat to that is
this understanding of sleep debt so we
don't understand sleep debt properly
people think it's an eye for an eye
i lose four hours i must gain four hours
well what happens when your body
being as efficient as it is doesn't
actually need you to gain an extra four
hours of sleep to recover you
your expectation is that it should and
when your expectation doesn't get met
you get upset about it and you change
your behavior
and that's when you start getting sleep
problems when the reality is your brain
is so smart
that even in the certain amount of hours
that you get normally at night
it can recover you from that sleep
deprivation by just improving or
increasing the sleep stage that it
thinks you miss the most for example
but because we have a lack of education
we believe we don't get some sleep
we need to regain that sleep and when we
don't regain that sleep
that's when the anxieties and the stress
is over not sleeping start so that's a
big one the sleep debt one
the other one is this idea that fatigue
and sleepiness are the same things
so yes when we don't sleep well we get a
lot of fatigue
so fatigue is anything from feeling like
your
body needs to rest to needing to shut
your eyes to
pain to your brain buzzing because
you've been working so hard for like 48
hours straight and you don't know what
to do with yourself
but the only definition of sleepiness is
the ability to shut your eyes and within
a few minutes
you're falling asleep so if you were
saying to me right now steph i am so so
sleepy i'd probably say to you well you
don't look it
because right now you don't look tired
in the way that i would expect you to be
falling asleep i mean you wouldn't be
able to sit still
you you would be sort of probably your
eyes would be shutting all the time
dozing off having little micro sleeps
that sleepiness
and that's what we should really be
understanding as a cue
to sleep so in the evenings if you're
not feeling that
then don't be don't be worried give
yourself permission to stay up later
because you can't dictate what happens
to you during the day and there are so
many variables that affect your sleep
you are never going to be able to
control
them having good sleep hygiene how many
good sleepers do you know have it
so good sleep hygiene is all these
things that we get told we should do so
the 10 top things that you should do
have a warm bath never drink coffee ever
again
um never have alcohol you know all these
things that you're supposed to do
but if you look at good sleepers are
they following all those things no
they're not and they're still sleeping
really well
and that's to show that most of the time
sleeping poorly comes down to
brain training and the patterns we get
ourselves into
you start going to bed early you might
be able to get to sleep earlier but
you're probably not going to be able to
have that sleep all the way through the
night because at some point or another
your body's going to be like well you've
had enough now but your expectation is
you should be able to sleep till seven
and why didn't i sleep till seven or if
you lie
in you keep changing the goal post of
your wake-up time which is the most
important thing
that you should be looking at not your
bedtime um if you keep changing that
goal post your body doesn't know when to
feed you it doesn't know when to make
you feel alert because
you've changed everything and so of
course you're not going to be
sleepy at the right time the time you
wake up is the
much more important time to be focused
on yes the things
your morning routine is going to be way
more important than your evening routine
when it comes to your sleep at night but
be because people see that as a far away
time
compared to when you go to sleep they
don't really focus on it in fact
haven't we been taught in this society
that lying in as a luxury
i can't believe that we have made it
okay at the weekend
to lie in so much but during the week
one of the only things
that gets us up is work it makes
absolutely no sense to me
i'm not saying it's the worst thing in
the world i'm not saying i never lie
in but i don't use it as a compensatory
method for a bad night's sleep because
that's when you're going to get into
trouble
because that's kind of throwing your
your your schedule up is that what
you're saying yeah
yeah so if you line on the weekends and
you're going to pay for it at some point
yeah
why are we not looking you know if you
have to lie in so significantly every
single weekend
why are we not looking at during the
week and thinking why am i doing this to
myself
at the time when i need it the most i
would choose to get less sleep and then
at the weekend i'll just compensate
and people and you much of the
conversation around sleep and society
talks about the amount of hours and it's
almost like
the amount of hours that i was in the
bed
um what's your sort of rebuttal to that
because quality over quantity every
single time
every single time and if you have good
quality and you need
longer your body will tell you and you
will get more sleep
but people are so obsessed with duration
and i i think people don't understand
what i mean by sleep opportunity i mean
every single night most of the time so
about eighty percent of the time i will
give myself a seven to eight hour sleep
opportunity sleep window but i do not
mean that if i'm not sleepy
i take myself into a dark room and shut
myself down
i just know that it's there i've got a
bedroom a place i really want to be to
sleep
that is available to me during those
hours and i will not
sleep outside those hours and that's the
that is the big thing
is you can dictate to your body when you
don't sleep
but you cannot dictate when you do and
by doing that you will
force your body to be in a nice regular
cycle
it's actually really really simple once
you know how to do it and every time i
fix someone of their insomnia there
and honestly 50 60 years of insomnia
they often turn around to me they're
like i don't know why i wasn't taught
this
when i was younger and i do believe if
we taught everyone how to sleep properly
give them a proper sleep education
when they're little i wouldn't exist
insomnia wouldn't exist
you talked there when you referenced
your own bedroom i think you
spoke about it quite lovingly it's about
this place i like to sleep how important
is that how important is it
to sleep in the same place and for that
space to be
is there a certain way i should be
designing my bedroom is there like a bed
that's good or like a pillow
because there's lots of fads around yeah
yeah there's a lot of fans around
i think your environment is important
but i can't dictate to you what that is
because we're all
so different um yes it's true
you don't need loads of technology in
your bedroom to sleep i'm not saying
technology can't aid our sleep because i
think in the future we're going to come
up with some crazy cool things that are
going to really help us
i just think right now we're not quite
there i think the least you have in your
bedroom that reminds you of the day
is really important so obviously screens
and light
is very important when it comes to sleep
but i think people mis
are missing a trick when when we say
don't look at your phones we're not just
saying don't look at your phones because
of the light exposure
we're saying it because it's reminding
your brain of something that you did
during the day
and so your brain being the smart thing
that it is is thinking
okay well i'll um i'll i'll increase
your cortisol
and i'll reduce your melatonin which is
your stress and your sleepy hormone
uh hormones um and i'm gonna help you be
more alert because
you clearly want to be alert right now
and so your brain thinks it's helping
you
and then you're thinking hang on a
minute i just looked at my phone for
like three seconds and now i'm
buzzing why and it's just because your
brain is
your your behavior is so much more
influential on your physio
physiology than you realize what do you
think about the snooze button
um i think if you have to use it on a
regular basis you need to start
questioning why you always need to
snooze
unfortunately the research shows that
snoozing does not benefit us
at all and actually if you think about
it if if you are a snoozer
you know how many times does that
actually make us feel better
exactly delays sorry no i think it's
nonsense as well i did i
one of my modules when i was doing
psychology in school was about sleep and
um
understanding the different phases of
sleep made me realize that the snooze
button is
i think totally pointless because you
have to be
in a certain phase of sleep for you to
get real benefits and
within 15 minutes you're not going to
get into that phase right absolutely
um a lot of people when they you know
when they
knew that i'm speaking to you today um
they want to know how they can sleep
better
in the short term tonight they're
looking for some kind of quick fix to
the to a problem they've had for a long
time what would you say to those people
okay so the first thing i'd say is that
you're never going to find that reactive
very quick method it's never going to
happen and even if you find it i promise
you
it won't work in the long term it might
control your condition in the short term
but not in the long term
i can teach you how to re to sleep but
it's going to take you
a a a few weeks not a night um but in
the meantime
don't worry it's okay like part part of
this is i just
there is a solution so what i do is
called cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia it is not the same as cbt for
depression or anxiety or anything else
um and it is just about retraining
yourself to sleep and building up that
strong sleep drive you have to do that
over time
but in the short term i usually tell
people that they do not need to worry
nothing bad is going to happen to you
and the reality is
that it's more your mood that will
affect your day when you wake up in the
morning
than the bad night's sleep you just had
so i know we've got evidence to show
that when you have a bad night's sleep
your cognitive abilities etc are going
to be
um reduced however if you think about
how you generalize that
you're not you're not going to lose your
job you're not going to perform
horrifically in that meeting because you
didn't get a good night's sleep
it would be far better for you to go to
bed later and make sure you're
lovely and sleepy and only get four
hours than to go to bed eight hours
before that meeting
and toss and turn and be fidgety and
stressed and anxious all night that's
what i do i still get
nervous when i have to do like a lecture
in front of 500 people of course i get
nervous
but instead of you know focusing on my
notes just before i go to bed i'll put
everything aside
i'll go and enjoy myself do something i
really love to do
i'll get ready for bed a bit earlier
than usual just so that i do not have to
think about anything when i get sleepy
and when i am sleepy even if it's two
three four hours later than usual
i know that i'll go and have a really
lovely
three or four hours sleep and then i'll
wake up and i'll be like great i know
i'm gonna be a bit sleepy today but
that's only gonna help me sleep tonight
and i'm gonna have an epic day i don't
care that i'm a bit sleepy sleepiness is
amazing sleepiness is such a good thing
for you
why are we teaching people that
sleepiness is a bad thing you need
sleepiness to sleep
i've got two questions though the first
i'm sure is it feels like a very
um related sort of question to what
you've just been talking about there
which is
do you sleep well i'm sure you get asked
this all the time at every party every
time you
it's like asking a comedian to tell a
joke right yeah yeah it's like
how was your sleep okay so most of the
time my sleep is fairly good because
i've been lucky enough to be educating
myself through this for
the last 16 years but it's not good all
the time because it's totally normal
after some kind of life stressor new
illness
some dramatic change in our society
like we're seeing right now for your
sleep to change and for it to be poor
okay it is totally normal to have sleep
problems
we will all get them you will never find
someone who does not have
a sleep problem at some point in their
lives but there is a difference between
somebody who has a short-term sleep
problem
and when the initial issue resolves
itself the sleep problem goes away
and the person who has now unfortunately
got
a long-term sleep problem the difference
is
the behavior it is not the person it is
not some trait that you have over
someone is not something genetic
there are there are all of those things
that do feed into
for example insomnia but the reality is
the thing that seems to perpetuate sleep
problems is not usually the original
trigger so we cannot blame the divorce
for example 20 years ago i'm not
divorced but i'm just making an example
so 20 years ago we get divorced and it's
a really stressful situation and it
stops you sleeping for a month okay
but now you're remarried and you're
perfectly happy but you've got a 20-year
insomnia problem
we cannot blame the divorce for that
anymore and also
somebody else who's gone through the
same situation same illness or divorce
or
new medication would not have had that
sleep problem 20
years later so what is it and i believe
and we know that most of it is your
behavior
after a few weeks of a sleep problem
most people will freak out and they'll
start changing their behavior
so they might start lying in they might
start going to bed early
they're trying desperately to improve
their sleep opportunity because they
believe the mere act
of lying in a bed for longer is going to
miraculously
give them a stronger sleep drive and
make them get through whatever it is
they need to get through
when the reality is and this is usually
how we treat insomnia or one of the ways
we actually deprive you of your sleep
opportunity so we don't deprive you of
sleep but we do deprive you of your
sleep opportunity so we
only allow you to be in bed for a
certain amount of time and that fixes it
but that's frightening because with
teaching people that sleep is so bad or
not sorry not sleep is so bad but
sleepiness is so bad that they don't
feel that they can build up that strong
sleep drive without something terrible
happening to them
so the way we are disseminating
knowledge right now is
not working and we have got to find a
way to change that
you talked about the type of therapy you
offer cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia
one of the elements you've described is
this sleep
deprivation which is in essence you're
stopping people sleeping i'm guessing
throughout the day to focus them on
their sleep opportunity
um yes so it's less about restricting
their sleep and more about restricting
their bedtime so often when you come
across somebody who's had a sleep
problem for a fair while enough to come
to see me
they're usually spending more time in
bed than they are sleeping so for
example they might be
in bed for around 10 hours but they're
only sleeping for say
six hours and so what i would do is i
would restrict them in the first
instance only so it's only mildly
to six hours in bed because or five
hours in bed whatever they're sleeping
for
i would we would we would never really
go lower than five hours because at the
end of the day we're only
um sort of guess it's all a bit of
guesswork here
um and that's important that it's like
that and we're not over tracking sleep
because that's has its own issues
um and then for a week or so i'll keep
them on that schedule and try and get
them to strictly stick to it which is
quite
scary for somebody who thinks the total
opposite way
is going to fix them even though they've
got no evidence that it works it doesn't
matter they've been doing it for a long
time so it's quite hard to get someone
to do this
and then once we can get them to sleep
for around 90
of that five or six hours whatever they
spend in bed
then we can start increasing their sleep
time out very very slowly
but people sort of get very over eager
about this it's called sleep restriction
therapy um
or there's lots of different ways of
calling it and people get over excited
about it and they're obsessed with
reaching that 90 percent efficiency so
they can move on and add
time but i try to always explain to
people
and indeed i do online courses in sleep
that they can do themselves and i'm
always trying to explain to them
it's not about adding more time imagine
if you are getting to
five or six hours sleep efficient every
every night for seven days as an average
that's really good that's so much better
than the broken sleep you were getting
before
think about the new quality that you
have built how amazing is that
when's the last time you went for a week
and you had that consistent sleep
and when they start thinking about it
that way they're like oh my god yes this
is so much better
and i'm even able to add more time now
and we slowly incrementally
start adding sleep out and that's how
you fix it i mean it's not everything
because you've got to work on the
mindset you've got to work on the
re-educating people what are those other
pieces of the
therapy yeah you gotta so first of all
one is the
sort of sleep restriction as you called
it yeah one area
is you we need to you've got to be
re-educated on sleep
much like we've been chit-chatting away
today that's how i will talk to someone
and i will try to help them understand
um i'll try and pick out a lot of the
things that they talk to me about
um but it's trying to help them
understand where the myths are where the
facts are with sleep because
a lot of their ideologies around sleep
will be directly influencing their
behavior
and so as soon as you can change that
and it's not as simple as just saying
that's right and that's wrong
you've got to keep doing it and they
need to trust you and and you've got to
find a way in the right language to
speak to that person
once you've done that you can start with
the sleep restriction
and then of course whilst there is no
evidence that relaxation or anxiety
reduction is going to directly
and reactively fix a long-term sleep
disorder
after you've started improving your
sleep drive and using the sleep
restriction therapy to do that
then yes we do need to start looking at
how do you bring yourself back to
balance during the day
is it stress and anxiety that got you
here in the first place because you're
working too much and you got yourself
into the wrong patterns
how are you going to process more during
the day how are you going to balance
more during the day
we need to look at those things but we
need to look at them with the right
expectations which is that they are not
going to make you sleep
because once that expectation is not met
you feel really inadequate
and then you feel like nothing can help
you and then you get hopeless and out of
control and lonely about your
problem so all this lots of different
sort of elements
like a pyramid to try and help someone
with their sleep
and you know people um cat caffeine has
become a huge part of our
you know we live in a society where
people take caffeine to wake them up and
then quite often they'll take certain
supplements to shut them down again like
sleep
new supplements or um various knighthold
i think is one of them right i don't
know
yeah yeah um what's your take on all of
all of these chemicals we're using
to kind of regulate our alertness and
then our tiredness
they just they can't work overtime so
all the research shows that eventually
you either get used to them they stop
working they make you feel really
uncomfortable
i don't think there's anything wrong
with for example sleeping pills or using
caffeine in the short term
things like that um but starting to use
them long term they have their own
all of them have their own side effects
and over a long
time of use aren't very good for the
body and but in general they're just not
going
to they're not going to suddenly
miraculously reset your sleep button or
anything that's people seem to think
they're going to do
so i don't think relying on these things
in the short term is a bad thing every
now and again
but if you're relying on them every
single time you have a sleep problem
you're effectively making it worse
because your brain isn't learning
anything it is literally just being
giving a cheap method
like a fake sleep almost and that is
what you get from a lot of sedatives is
sedative sleep which is not the same as
the cycles that you go through
usually to sleep well so you're not
getting but psychologically
we believe that sleep is better than no
sleep and actually
i don't necessarily agree with that in a
way i'd rather get
no sleep than a really rubbish sleep
knowing that my body will like build up
a really strong sleep drive and help me
later
but people are so terrified of that that
they that psychologically they just need
to feel like they've slept
but if they had a bit of better
education around sleep and they
understood how it worked more
then i don't think people would be
trying to grab all these things all the
time but we live in a reactive society
we're not very proactive as creatures we
want
we want it now and we want it done
yesterday what about caffeine that's
such a huge part of
everybody's well pretty much everybody's
daily routine people
they you know they'll say i have to have
this coffee to wake myself up
yeah i have three or four of them a day
and then what impact does that end up
having on sleep
so caffeine is very interesting because
genetically we are all
either sensitive or not sensitive or
somewhere in between with caffeine so
it's very hard to say
nobody should be drinking caffeine after
this time yes it does have a very
sort of it has a big afterlife so it
definitely
or half-life so what we mean by that is
that um
you know it's going to have an effect on
you hours and hours after you've had it
but depending on how sensitive
you're to to it you are you know but at
the same time there's so much more you
can do if you started waking up at the
same time every day
you would start to feel refreshed you
would be one of those people who wakes
up and is like yeah
i'm ready to start the day imagine if
you just used your body the way it was
designed to be used
i'm not saying caffeine is bad i
definitely wouldn't say
you can't drink caffeine but if you're
starting to use it
anything in life in anything chemical in
a compensatory method because something
is wrong
that's when you need to start
questioning it but in general having
caffeine in the morning i don't think
there's anything wrong with that if you
enjoy it
great but then there's lots of research
that shows that even your performance
isn't
significantly improved by having
caffeine you might feel like you're able
to buzz around everything more but your
actual efficiency
isn't necessarily improved i i wonder
you know because
i think i was looking at some stats
around insomnia and sleep so
sleep disorders and the stats are pretty
staggering and
i don't know how to say this but i just
don't tend to believe that
humans after all these thousands of
years of evolution
have been born with quite an
apparent or seemingly apparent um
problem with sleep so it makes me think
okay so what is it in our
social um environment and society
that's making us struggle with sleep
is it our over obsession with the
perfect sleep that might be one element
and this you know and all the fear and
anxiety around not sleeping perfectly as
you've described and we're actually
doing pretty good
yeah right and labeling ourselves as
insomnia you know because that word
i'm an insomniac or insomnia it's thrown
around pretty yeah
absolutely or is it the you know the
tech in our lives is it the the
over stimulation of the you know the
technology we have is it overworking
what's your take on that because i feel
the same about depression and anxiety as
well
i look at the stats growing over
time um in ver with various sort of
mental um
illnesses and i think surely we weren't
born
um with chemical imbalances
as is um said in um yeah i love them
yeah i so it's a hard question to answer
i think that there is element there's
lots of different elements i don't
believe that the stats
are as accurate as they probably seem
for example i believe that before you
know the industrial revolution for
example
we had um sleep problems i i mean i
no i do i believe we did it's just that
i believe we're recording things now
more so there's that aspect of it
there is this aspect of we over worry
about things and you know at the end of
the day while someone
keep you know lots of people out there
keep telling us that actually
um you know if you sleep less than six
hours you will die early
but actually we're not actually seeing
that today um
yeah how much am i reducing my life
expectancy with my poor sleep the thing
is
okay so if you know you've got poor
sleep you need to improve it but
hopefully it's not going to be long term
you can actually get some support for
that and get it sorted if you're
actively
keeping yourself at five hours when you
know you're a seven hour sleeper
then yeah you're going to reduce your
life expectancy but if you're naturally
a five hour sleeper and they do exist
then that does not mean the same thing
that you're going to be reducing your
life expectancy
when genetically you can't you know
that's for you
um it's really difficult to understand i
think um you know electricity has a big
part to play so
again i talked a little bit briefly at
the beginning about the light dark
cycles of this planet
and the way that we are designed or not
designed but you know we're built
on this planet we we seem to have
evolved that way
um and so we we we definitely do need to
be
in general not uh working and resting
more at night and we
we work better our metabolisms our
brains function we're more rational
during the day um and so with
electricity has become
many problems i definitely think the
scaremongering
and the fear and the tracking of sleep
has definitely caused in the last few
years
a boom in sleep problems or at least how
many people are coming to us for help
and with the the pandemic what impact
has that had on people's sleep
heel let's talk about heal for a second
i've spent a lot of time on this podcast
talking about the ready to drink your
bottles which are my favorite for
convenience reasons it means i don't
have to mix anything
but this week as my goals in gym and in
my health in my physique have started to
evolve
i've started using a new product that i
wanted to tell you about and
the reason why i've started using this
product which is called huel the black
edition
is because there's 50 less carbs
33 more protein um
zero artificial sweeteners and it's of
course gluten free i wish i had
something like this
to be honest when i was a student
because
it's literally one pound 47 per meal
i think you get about 17 or 18 meals out
of one bag
and if you're someone like me that in
this phase of my life that's trying to
build a bit of
muscle get a little bit more lean whilst
also you know
reducing the carbs a little bit then
give black edition huel
a try and try the vanilla flavor if you
do get a chance because that's
um for me is the the tastiest flavor of
them all and
do you know what i'm gonna do next week
in the podcast i'm gonna take my top off
okay so
i'm gonna um show you the impact that uh
all of this being a huel again has had
for me you're gonna have to tune in next
week and you're gonna have to watch it
on youtube to see
that but um i'm gonna show you the the
before and after
of using huel and uh uh and before i
used to
okay so that's something to look forward
to or maybe not
with the the pandemic what impact has
that had on people's sleep
it's had a huge impact so um in various
different ways so the first way is that
everybody's routine changed and
because we couldn't go outside and move
as much as we once did we couldn't get
as much light exposure as we once did we
didn't get as much stimulation social
stimulation
so our brains weren't being used in the
same way plus we all had this sort of
uh thing to look at on the news all the
time so we're actively sort of looking
at something that is stressing us out
and making us
anxious so various different components
no wonder sleep changed
but it would have been totally normal
for that to happen your sleep is
adapting to your new
environment and so when people start
worrying about this i try to get them to
calm down about it because actually if
your sleep wasn't working properly
you just wouldn't be here okay so to a
degree our sleep is doing a bloody good
job for us
um and we need to be better about it we
blame sleep for everything
um and actually there's so many other
variables that we can control in our
lives that will have an effect on us
but yes during the pandemic we saw um or
we still see
there's plenty more problems with people
struggling to get to sleep maybe they're
feeling really buzzy
and they can't get to sleep maintaining
that sleep so people waking up in the
middle of the night and they're just
like
what why am i waking up sometimes they
they've got million thoughts
a minute or um sometimes they're just
thinking of nothing and they don't know
why that's happening
we've seen more dream recall very
graphic dreams
and we believe that's because obviously
when your routine changes and you don't
have to work
and ironically i always say to
insomniacs that actually when they're
working and when they've got busy lives
it's a lot easier to treat them
than when they don't have a routine
because routine is
everything to our bodies i wish we
understood
more how much our bodies love to be
regulated and going to work
and doing exercise and going to see our
friends and going to the gym
and eating at regular intervals is
telling your brain
so many signals the light exposure you
get
is telling your brain about how much
melatonin to
release for you it's fascinating but we
do need regulation and the biggest thing
that changed
during this pandemic was our routines
people people have a real desire as well
you mentioned the the the fact that the
pandemic had caused very like vivid
dreams
people have asked me so many times if
they can control their dreams how do
they stop themselves
streaming so vividly or um and some
people having you know recurring
nightmares and things like that
what what is your answer to that what
control do we have on our dreams so you
can you can learn to
that's what we call lucid dreaming so
you can learn to lucid dream the problem
is it's probably not very good for your
sleep in general
um so effectively when we remember our
dreams it's because we have been woken
out of rem sleep so rem
is actually a very active stage of sleep
it's not your deep sleep it's actually
quite a light stage of sleep
some might argue that's even a different
state of consciousness and not sleep at
all
so rem is a really strange time it's
when we believe that more of our memory
and our psychological restoration
is happening in consolidation and things
like that and part of rem we tend to
have more
graphic dreams but it's it's you being
interrupted from that state which you
may not remember in the night it could
just be a van driving past
in your rem sleep and it wakes you into
a lighter stage of sleep like stage one
or two sleep
and so in the morning you think oh my
god i really remember my dreams or maybe
your alarm woke you up in the middle of
rem sleep and you're like oh my god i
can really remember my dreams
as opposed to the times when you're like
i didn't dream at all last night well of
course you did dream
it's just that your rem wasn't
interrupted so that's why you're
remembering your dreams
when we try to control our dreams
usually you have to kind of control that
interruption a bit and so
i haven't looked into it properly in
terms of lucid dreaming because it
doesn't really help me do my job i don't
really want people to learn to lucid
dream because then
one they're going to be remembering
their dreams more and if they're
remembering their dreams more than their
sleep is more interrupted and that's not
good for your sleep we want you to go
through the cycles of sleepers
as uh you know as comfortably as we can
and so that you get all the right
percentages and all the right
restoration
and and healing and everything that you
need from your sleep
and so yeah it's an interesting concept
i don't think it's very helpful to
healthy sleep
but every now and again especially kids
i find when i'm talking to children
they seem to be able to control their
dreams a little bit better like flying
for example
they concentrate more on it that's why
so they have more time and they
concentrate on
it which is quite a fun thing maybe we
should all be
doing more of that daydreaming and stuff
it's actually really good for problem
solving
um so yeah it's fascinating and and
there's a lot of
famous people i think einstein though
don't i mean
i don't know if i'm right about this but
einstein and various other
geniuses would do things like hold a
um egg or or a spoon or something um
so that if and when they fell asleep
that spoon would drop
and then they would wake up because they
felt they had all their best ideas
i can see you looking at me and thinking
about doing this to get better
tonight but it's not very good for sleep
to keep interrupting it like that
um so you can yes you've got the power
to manipulate sleep however you want but
at the end of the day if the goal here
is to keep you alive for longer and to
feel refreshed in the day
and to have your best ideas consistently
and to be healthy consistently then you
probably want to do sleep right the way
it was designed
and what about what i eat before i go to
bed a lot of people talk about that
that's another
uh thing you know if i order food really
late someone will turn to me in the room
and go oh you should be in at this time
you know what i mean what do i say
tomorrow okay i've said it before
a good sleeper does all the wrong things
and they seem to be okay
but they're probably not doing all the
wrong things all the time so yes
the the later you eat you're basically
asking your body to metabolize and
asking it to sleep and it does
not like doing both and so one of them
will be um
compromised um in terms of um
anything that you can eat that will have
a significant effect on your sleep
there's no real research there is
research to show things like you know if
you
if you eat enough cherries or you have
enough milk or enough turkey
it's going to give you some kind of
sedatory effect but at the end of the
day
it's you'd have to have a stupid amount
of those kind of foods to have any kind
of effect
it's not going to help you sleep
healthily from day to day that's not
going to suddenly
boost the quality of your sleep um
significantly
and so i would argue that unless you
have some kind of deficiency in a
vitamin or mineral
that is affecting your sleep then you
probably don't need to be looking at
the food you eat in general as i'm sure
a lot of people will say but in general
eating a healthy balanced diet where you
have what you would call naughty foods
and good foods and
in balance all that stuff is really good
for you and probably the only piece of
advice i'd give around eating is
again regulating how you eat so if it's
breakfast lunch and dinner you like to
do trying to do that at consistent times
every single day is going to help your
body understand when you want to be
awake and metabolizing and when you want
to be sleeping
and then not sleeping too late at night
just so that you can
make sure that your body metabolizes
well and sleeps well
and can i sleep too much is that such a
people people there's this myth again in
society where people think that
they overslept and now they're knackered
right so
yeah so you can it usually when people
say they've overslept if we actually
looked at them in a sleep study and
they've overslept for the amount that
they
usually sleep and they didn't need it
probably the quality of their entire
sleep wouldn't be
amazing um and that's why they were able
to have this dribble drabbily longer
sleep and
and it's not it's not going to be very
helpful but usually when we're talking
about that research that shows that
longer sleepers actually
can get sicker um is because the quality
of their sleep is impaired by something
like sleep apnea or
another sleep disorder which is
impairing the quality of their sleep so
yeah so poor quality sleep you're gonna
sleep longer it's kind of the same as
having insomnia because you're not
really sleeping
and so therefore you feel you need to
sleep longer and you wake up and you
still
don't feel like you've slept as much as
you needed to
if you're sleeping really well from
night to night you don't need to sleep
more so your body won't really let you
so if the quality is good
and you've reached that optimal time
you'll notice that if you do try to
sleep longer
it's quite if i looked at that sleep for
you in a polysomnography study so i
looked at your brain activity
the quality of it is just like a snooze
is probably not going to be the same
it's not going to be
but it's very rare you find someone like
usually they're deprived of something or
rather or
they have been sleeping properly and
then they sleep a bit longer
you hear a lot of them a lot of
successful people i think it's it's part
of bragging
you know bragging about how little they
sleep that's how i only sleep three four
hours a day and
i think it's pushed this idea into a
society that in order to be successful
you've gotta
sleep for you know just two or three
hours or four hours whatever
but then on the other side you have this
total contradiction which is
in order to be successful you need to
wake up at 6am and drink green juice and
do yoga and like
sleep for exactly seven hours um and it
and it
i guess this kind of speaks to the
original point which was um
that there's so much over-generalization
and uh through an attempt to sell you
something whether it's the book or um
my authority or to get you to follow me
yeah i kind of preach this secret
yeah quite easily replicated for all of
you
right yeah that's causing us to to be
like uh be smart
like smacked with these contradicting
narratives around sleep
um which is making everyone a little bit
confused um what's your sort of take on
all of that because
you know as when i was growing up i
thought you know if i want to be
successful i've got to just sleep less
and i i think if i'm being completely
honest with myself
i think i used to be proud of how little
i sleeped yeah i thought it was like a
war
like a badge of honor you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah but now i think i'm getting a
little bit older and i'm
i don't really give a [ __ ] for what
people think yeah good good
um uh so yeah i i definitely have seen a
change around in this recently but yeah
there has been
this thing about like clean sleeping
it's a bit like the whole clean eating
thing it's a consent
it's a it's everything that you've
effectively just said um but people
trying to say you need to do this that
and that to have the perfect night's
sleep
actually that doesn't really exist once
you know how much sleep you need
around make sure you have that
opportunity most nights that you're
how do i know though um so i guess you
referenced genetics
you said there are five hours yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i guess
um a more relaxed way of looking at it
is
when you go on holiday after the three
four days of recovery
from you know work life um what happens
you know left your own devices what
happens
and that's a pretty good way of looking
at it if you're looking at a really
scientific way then sleep restriction
therapy so what we would put a insomniac
through
also will show you how much of a
duration that you need right now because
there'll be a point where you can't keep
adding time
your body won't get you to 90 efficient
and that's where you know
okay maybe this is around the right time
for me and
sleeping mental health i feel like it's
i don't know my guess would be that it's
somewhat
kind of a a cycle right i think poor
sleep might lead to poor mental health
and then poor men's health might lead to
poor sleep
is that accurate you're absolutely right
but it doesn't matter what came first
the chicken or the egg the main
issue is especially in medicine and i've
just done a piece of research
and that shows that undergraduate
medical degrees
only teach a median of an hour and a
half of sleep so this is why this next
thing happens a lot
because they just don't have the
education so our own doctors do not have
enough education in something that we do
a third of our lives
so historically or traditionally when
you go to your gp
and you say i've got a sleep problem
they'll tell you you've got depression
and insomniacs will be able to relate to
this and it is because
in general we look at sleep or poor
sleep as a symptom
of another condition now even if it is
even if you do have a significant mental
health problem and it is causing you to
have sleep issues
if it's been longer than three months
you now have a
entrained sleep disorder and you need to
be treating the sleep problem as a
primary condition
in itself and the one that i would treat
first is whichever one is most prevalent
so whichever symptoms seem to be more
distressing for you at the time is where
i would start but i would be fixing
for example the depression and the
insomnia
separately and the results show that
when you treat insomnia you have less
relapse
of depression because you have actually
resolved one of these things that
unfortunately was perpetuating
everything
so it doesn't really matter where sleep
comes into it but you've got to
give it its own podium it needs to be it
is a pillar of health
and you need to treat it that way you
reference a good sleeper and bad sleeper
what's the uh what are the
characteristics of each
so everyone always thinks i'm going to
say well a good sleeper does this and a
good sleeper does that but actually the
only difference i have
seen over however long doing this is
that a good sleeper is somebody who just
doesn't worry that much about their
sleep they are very grateful for their
sleep
and they're very you know you know they
they give themselves
a fair opportunity they don't always
sleep well
they don't you know sometimes they have
sleep problems but they don't get overly
bothered by it and they notice that
their sleep when left to its own devices
will go back
to whatever it needs to be about 10 of
insomniacs we never see because they
don't perceive themselves to be having a
problem
and they're not sick and dying isn't
this somewhat uh
i guess a metaphor for the for the rest
of our lives as well where
typically much of the problem is people
thinking that they have a problem or
their own perception
of their reality because i'll be honest
um
everyone around me doesn't think i sleep
very well
but i've always thought that i slept
really really well and i've just
i think refused to buy into the idea
that i'm a bad sleeper they think that
because i'm up at strange times
sometimes i'm traveling extreme but i
i've never worried about my sleep when i
go into my room eventually i'll fall
asleep and at some point i'll wake up
but i guess the point i'm trying to make
there is as well if you look at what's
happening in the world
with the pandemic and you know people
feeling certain
um feeling like they should be
a certain way is actually making them
that way people feeling like they should
feel self-pity is making them feel
self-pity
and um as someone that's been to
rio de janeiro and seen the um the
favelas there and spent time in the
favelas but also i've been to india and
spent some time in the harvey i think
they call it which is
you know known as the slums which i
think is a derogatory term
um i've seen people in this in the slums
in india
who were significantly happier um
than people that i know that are very
you know
relatively cushy and i know it's all
subjective
living in the uk and it just but people
hate when we talk about these these
these things because it gets the mirror
of blame
and responsibility and it just turns it
back on themselves and says maybe you're
the problem
yeah maybe the way you're thinking is
the problem and maybe you can do
something about it
yeah absolutely you've hit the nail on
the head um
i like i said about 10 of insomniacs we
we never see
and actually if you think about it
insomnia is just
another pattern of sleep and you have a
certain pattern of sleep right now and
if it's not
broken do not fix it i firmly believe
that and if you ever have a problem well
you know where i am
um but hopefully you never will because
you'll follow
your gut follow what you feel is right
um
if that turns you awry then fair enough
um get some support but actually
you you really have hit the nail on the
head and i really do believe
with a bit more understanding and
education around sleep and that it's not
night to night your sleep doesn't work
like that i get yes
we do need to most of the time
sleep night to night but it can survive
without doing that
um it is it's incredible if we spent
more time understanding how amazing
sleep was rather than fearing when it
doesn't happen and then blaming it for
absolutely everything
we would be in a much better position we
would cherish it more
and we would um you know love it more
but not
overly put pressure on it which is
ridiculous sleep cannot
force you to lose your job sleep can't
do though or lack of it
it just can't um but our belief that it
does
is making this problem worse so yes it
is a hundred percent a mindset i spend
most of my time not training people to
sleep again
but actually trying to help resolve that
mindset one of the last things i do
when i finish with a client is i have to
go through and help them understand
that sleep is not the be-all and end-all
because actually even to treat their
sleep i have to get them to focus on it
and actually i need to take the focus
away now and one of the exercises i do
is i tell them look
i now want you to think that we're in a
world where sleep doesn't exist and when
i do that people are like oh my god that
would be awful
because it would just be one long
perpetual day we'd never finish our day
just philosophically and psychologically
how would we deal with that
and actually i'm like yes that's how you
should be thinking about it because that
time
even when you're not sleeping is
beautiful and we should cherish it
um and also if you didn't sleep what
would be all the other variables that
would affect you and i start getting
them to think about the rest of their
lives and all these other things like
exercise and eating right and they're
just the basics
who you interact with when you watch the
news the bills you paid that day whether
you walk to the dog
um all sorts of things pain um noisy
neighbors
uh your commute to work how many of
those things actually have a
properly significant impact on you but
you'll still blame it on your sleep
and then it's a perpetual cycle because
then you start compensating well i'm not
going to do this anymore i'm not going
to
go to the gym i'm not going to see my
friends i'm terrified it's going to do
something that affects my sleep
and then your sleep is worse because
your body's now thinking oh
so she doesn't need to get good sleep at
night because she's not doing anything
in the day anymore
and so you make it worse and worse and
worse and that is one of the biggest
things i see
in a long-term insomniac is somebody
who's literally stopped living
in order to fix the problem why do we
think that's going to fix the problem
it doesn't what about a bad sleeper then
so we talked a little bit about the pro
like the profile of the characteristics
of a good sleeper what's a bad sleeper
so a bad sleeper is somebody who really
does um
they get bad sleep and suddenly they
start worrying about the lack of sleep
and then what they'll do is they'll look
up how do i fix my sleep they'll come up
with 10
regimented rules and they'll start
becoming obsessive and ritualistic about
those rules
they'll stop going out in the evening
and they'll start having the hot one
bath
the herbal tea and every single thing
that they have
um they think and they know it doesn't
work but they're so
terrified of not doing them because
that's all they've got to hold on to now
that they are um you know they they they
can't go away from it
and actually trying to take teach those
people to sleep better
is is harder than somebody who's a bit
more relaxed around their
routine because they've built these
things up so hard you know what's really
funny is um
what you've described there is a person
who is so
keen to solve a problem that probably
isn't that much of a problem that
they've
they're in search of these techniques
and tips and secrets and
shortcuts and whatever probably a lot of
the people that felt compelled to click
on
this podcast today to listen to it and
you see the same within
uh success and ambition you see this
like
this certain group of people that i'm
gonna be honest
okay are almost never really successful
but spend the most time trying to be and
when i when i think about my success so
when i read these books about oh the
the perfect way to be successful here's
13 tips
that all successful people share i think
this is total [ __ ] nonsense because
my sleep is i sleep whenever i feel
tired as you say
i eat blah blah blah you know i don't do
yoga i don't like meditate every day i
don't i don't
follow any script or blueprint i just
kind of go with the flow and do my best
every single day and show up and try and
be better tomorrow
like if that that's as far as it goes
for me there's no looking in the mirror
and saying steve you're going to be a
millionaire steve you're going to be you
know what i mean
all of that feels like nonsense to me
but the people that seem to
um do those things the visualizations in
the mirror the
mood boarding my future like they're not
they are never the successful ones all
of my successful friends don't do that
yeah yeah and
um and i i maybe i think what i'm saying
is i
sounds like the same applies to sleep
yeah where like the the people that get
addicted on techniques and tips and
tricks
end up having the worst sleep overall
yeah what have we missed
i'm asking you this question because
there's so many unknown unknowns i don't
i don't know a ton about sleep
again because i've never really cared
that much about it right so
is there anything that you think we've
missed any specific topics or
i think i would love it if people came
away from this podcast and
gave their sleep a little bit of a break
and in the same
sort of with the same idea i'm sure
there'll be people
out there thinking yes but when i wake
up tonight in the middle of the night
what do i do about it so i guess this is
one thing we haven't covered
to understand that if you are waking up
in the middle of the night and it's been
happening to you
over and over again this has become a
habit
and therefore to resolve the habit
you're going to have to do something
consistently
you're not going to be able to solve it
in one night it's just not going to
happen however
if you're waking up and you're getting
stressed and anxious
do not lie in bed it's not going to help
you you've got a different problem now
you've made yourself anxious and
stressed and you need to alleviate it
leave the bedroom go and enjoy yourself
it is not going to wake you up you are
already awake your sleep drive clearly
isn't there to take you back to sleep so
go do something else
make sure you get up in the morning do
not lie in go and have
the epic day enjoy yourself go and see
your friends
or talk to them over zoom or go and do
some exercise get outside
get some light exposure be happy and
content in your life focus on other
things
and go to bed when you're really really
sleepy and when it happens again the
next night do the same thing
and i promise you eventually you will be
able to get out of it but if you lie
there and you get anxious and stressed
and you try and
force yourself to sleep you already know
this doesn't work you're trying it over
and over again
so don't do it so that's the thing i
would say i hope that when people listen
to this
they come away and they're like you know
what i'm not as worried as i was
about my sleep i'm actually going to
chill out and i'm going to be all right
about it
but if i do want to improve the quality
i've listened to what she said there's
some key things there i'm going to i'm
going to try do those few things
but it's about the little things so it's
not about doing 20 different things it
is just about literally get up at the
same time every morning stop
overcompensating stop diluting your
sleep opportunity when you don't get
good sleep
make it smaller build that sleepiness
it's actually good for you don't freak
out nothing bad is going to happen
and you you talked to one particular
point i wanted to come back on there
because
i when i asked my audience about the
questions they had for you
again about i say 15 20 of them were all
about
i keep waking up in the middle of the
night yeah yeah what to do so you're
saying get out of bed get out of bed and
go and do something that you love
do not yeah do not go and do something
like clean the bathroom
or do something boring go and do
something that is going to be
distracting
for god's sake we're always going on
about how little time we have you've got
more time now
so go and use it go and do something fun
i'm not saying get up and go to
work i'm not saying that because i still
think this is your sleep opportunity and
if you want to retrain your brain to
sleep during this time
then you've got to sort of do things
that are i'm not saying you need to
relax relax relax because i think people
get stressed at that term and they're
like i can't relax i don't know how to
relax don't make me do this
so i think what makes you happy do some
things that just make you happy whether
that's looking at old photos or
just doing something that you love it is
okay okay
it's not gonna be forever like i said
you cannot force yourself to sleep
but you can dictate when you don't sleep
so as long as you're not
overcompensating by lying in or going to
bed early because you're so worried
about the sleep that you've lost
forget it it's gone there's nothing you
can do about it so just move
on and do the right things and i promise
you you will start sleeping better
but the more you freak out and you're
worried about what is going to happen to
you if you don't sleep another night in
a row
the more you won't be able to fix the
problem great
where can people find you uh so i'm at
sleepyheadclinic.co.uk it's gone pretty
international now because
of the covid is literally i'm online now
um
and sleepyheadprogram.com if you have no
time to speak to me
or you just want to do it yourself um i
have set up this online course that you
can do
which i'm very excited about with two
awesome business partners who
are just as crazy and passionate about
sleep as i am
and hopefully we can start seeing more
people
um and and build on it and make it an
even better experience so
yeah listen thank you so much for your
time today um
sleep is a thing that i think is as i
said at the start the podcast has been
increased in relevance um in our society
in my personal conversations
online through instagram through books
that aren't as you say necessarily very
helpful so it's been
um very refreshing to to hear
a almost a counter narrative to the kind
of very binary
specific um quick
um secret orientated like hacks that
people push online and that's
uh i think will do a ton of people a lot
of good so thank you so much for coming
thank you so much for having me
thank you thanks
[Music]